the vast majority of news in the u.s. is
controlled by five huge corporations and
news voice is fighting back against
media monopolies it's the first-ever
entirely open crowd-sourced democratized
platform for news use the link right
underneath this video to download the
news voice app for free I have for you
today some of the absolutely strangest
video so far of Donald Trump's
presidency and that is a really high bar
given that almost all the video we have
of Donald Trump has been extraordinarily
strange and bizarre Donald Trump
complained about the flushing of toilets
hmm 10 to 15 times and about certain
light bulbs that he doesn't like he
talked about toilets or maybe it sinks
and showers quote not getting any water
none of it made any sense it sort of
seemed like it was maybe an attempt at
humor but Trump really has no sense of
humor some of it seemed like thinly
veiled compliment a complaints rather
about energy efficiency standards that
exist including around lightbulbs it was
a word salad to end all word salads it
was a three-star Michelin rated word
salad from Donald Trump let's take a
look at the video see if we can figure
anything out let's listen to this first
one but together we're defending the
American workers were using common sense
we have a situation where we're looking
very strongly at sinks and showers and
other elements of bathrooms where you
turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water
where the water rushes out to see
because you could never handle it and
you don't get any water you turn on the
faucet you don't get any water they take
a shower and water comes dripping out
just clipping out very quietly tripping
out people are flushing toilets 10 times
15 times as opposed to once they end up
using more water so EPA is looking at
that very strongly and my suggestion you
go into a new building or new
their new home and they have standards
only you don't get water you can't you
can't wash your hands practically this
old little water comes out of the faucet
and the end result is you leave the
faucet on and it takes you much longer
to wash your hands you end up using the
same amount of water so we're looking at
very seriously and opening up the
standard and there may be some areas
where we'll go the other route desert
areas but for the most part you have
many states where they have so much
water that it comes down as Colerain
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers and elements of bathrooms they
take a shower and water drips people are
flushing toilets 10 times what is Trump
doing that he's flushing a toilet 10 to
15 times for that it sounds reasonable
or likely to him that's one question
that this raises may be one for a
different day how can any Trump
supporter see this stuff and see
strength or leadership or intelligence
or cunning or cleverness how I need
someone to explain it to me please
here's another clip about the lightbulbs
and we're doing other things the light
bulb they get rid of the light bulb that
people got used to the new bulb is many
times more expensive and I hate to say
it it doesn't make you look as good of
course being a vain person that's very
important to me gives you an orange look
I don't want an orange has anyone
so we'll have to change those bulbs at
at least a couple of rooms where I am in
the white hand I saw some trumpet
comments comments online where they are
just fully convinced that this is all
comedy like it's all humor beyond just
Trump doesn't want to look orange that's
true but the toilets the showers it's
all humour according to some online
Trump astons if that's the case what's
the joke like what is the joke about
flushing a toilet ten to fifteen times
it's like when Trump said windmill
windfarms
cause cancer and some supporters said oh
that was a joke that was comedy well
like what what's the joke what's the
punchline I don't understand how that
even qualifies as a joke this was the
line during the campaign you might
recall every outrageous thing that
Donald Trump said was defended either as
listen Trump's just telling it like it
is he's not being politically correct
you won't hear this from a lot of other
politicians but Trump is just telling it
like it is or the other explanation for
equally crazy comments was he doesn't
literally mean everything he says these
are jokes this is humor you've got to
stop taking it all so seriously because
Donald Trump isn't actually speaking
seriously
well well is it which which is it is it
that everything is a joke or that
everything is serious and it's a truth
that nobody else is willing to tell you
but in all seriousness assuming that
this does all relate to building codes
if we want to try to assess what policy
might this actually be related to it's
Trump saying he doesn't like all the
building codes and he wants to look at
getting rid of them this is another
attack on sustainability this is yet
another attempt to undo environmental
regulations at every opportunity even
because of this vague ridiculous people
are flushing toilets 10 to 15 times
confusion and that's the policy concern
that underlies this that we shouldn't
forget at every opportunity that there
is an opportunity to either undo an
environmental regulation or just undo
something that Barack Obama did because
that's also another priority it doesn't
apply in all of these cases they are
doing it and the list of things that the
next president will hopefully have to
undo or
do as the as the case may more accurate
accurately be stated is a growing list
and this stuff matters I mean I know
that you know we've talked before
Elizabeth Warren she was asked during a
recent debate should the government get
to tell you what kind of light bulbs you
use and Elizabeth Warren astutely said
that's the wrong question a hundred
companies are responsible for seventy
something percent of all emissions in
this country the pollution the question
of straw or I think it was actually not
about light bulbs but maybe it was about
straws the the issue of straws is not
really the big issue what we have here
are much much bigger issues to tackle
they mostly relate to industry but if
you look at the entire country's
building and construction engine
industry and you look at these
guidelines and environmental standards
they do make a difference in the
aggregate and to laugh them off or to
pretend that the government wants you to
have a crappy toilet that can't you know
that Trump needs to flush ten times
because of whatever he's doing or
whatever the case may be it's another
one of these distractions and it is yet
another way that the sort of bonus or
priority for dealing with the
environmental destruction is at the
individual level it's the toilet I
choose it's the straw that I choose when
there are much bigger issues and they're
regulating there as well I think it's
important not to forget bizarre video
again just kooky video but it does
connect to serious issues related to
regulation and the environment and
climate change make sure you're
following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show make sure
you're also following me on instagram at
david pakman